حاله من الجدل شهدتها مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي خلال الساعات الماضيه قصه
البلوجر ارها في الشامي التي تزوجت من
زوجي صديقتها المقربه
بدات قصه رهف عندما نشرت صديقتها سلمى عبر
حسابها على موقع فيسبوك تدوينه قالت فيها
انها اكتشفت خيانه البلوجر لها وقالت سلمى
انها تفاجات بصور خطبتي زوجها لصديقتها
المفضله
رهف الشامي
الامر الذي اصابها بالصدمه خاصه ان
البلوجر رهف حضرت حفله زفافها قبل خمس
سنوات وتعرفت عليها على انها صديقه زوجها
منذ فتره طويله
[موسيقى]
واعتقدت سلمى حينها ان زوجها ورهف مجرد
اصدقاء لكنها تفاجات ان رهف كانت تربطوها
علاقه عاطفيه مع زوجها وقالت ان الاخيره
طلبت من زوجها ان يطلقها لكي توافق على
خطبته وبالفعل طلق سامح او الحسن سلمى منذ
شهر اغسطس الماضي وتقدم لخطبه البلوجر
عقبات الاكل
واكدت سلمى ان رهف الشامي كانت تتقرب منها
لاجل زوجها سامح وقامت بالغاء متابعتها
لها حتى لا تتمكن من رؤيته صور الخطوبه
وبعد ساعات من انتشار منشورات غضب واستياء
من البلوجر رهف الشامي وتصدر اسمها محركات
البحث خرجت رهف عن صمتها ورود قصه اخرى
عكس روايه طليقه خطيبها وقالت ان خطيبها
الحالك كان خطيبها قبل 10 سنوات ولكن
الخطبه لم تكتمل وتتم بالزواج وان السبب
في ذلك هي الزوجه السابقه لخطيبها التي
وضعت مكائده حتى وقعت بينهما وتزوجته هي
ونشرت عددا من القصص لتشرح الامر وبعد
ساعات قليله حذفتها وقالت
[موسيقى]
كم هو فقط رهف الشامي قصه حبها في مقطع
فيديو ريل على انستغرام عن الطريقه التي
تعرفت بها على خطيبها قبل عشر سنوات في
الجامعه
[موسيقى]